magic we just we're just so thrilled to
have joy
[Music]
everyone is lining up to meet Bibi
Archie's since its birth on May 6 the
big question is who will be as
godparents Megan and Harry have a big
decision to make and we're breaking down
all the likely candidates one important
thing to note with royal kiddos is they
typically have about 6 to 7 godparents
each Prince William and Kate Middleton
selected a mixture of friends confidants
extended family and even former aides to
fill the position for their three
children
George Charlotte and Louise and while
Prince Harry and Megan Markel do tend to
buck tradition we're expecting them to
follow suit with Archie let's start with
potential godmothers tennis champ Serena
Williams tops our list of contenders
she's one of Megan's closest friends and
a frequent visitor of the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex
Syrena even helped throw Megan's lavish
New York City baby shower earlier this
year and the Duchess has been known to
cheer Serena on courtside at Wimbledon
Megan even rocked a blazer from the
athletes clothing line while in
Australia last October Williams would be
a great choice to keep BB Archie close
to his American roots and heritage next
up Megan's designer friend mission nunu
who has also been part of Harry and
Williams close circle for years nunu is
rumored to be the matchmaker behind
Megan and Harry's first day in London
she's been a favored travel partner of
the Duchess and even hosted Megan in her
New York City penthouse prior to her
baby shower remember this now infamous
white husband shirt Megan sported for
her first public appearance with Harry
at the 2017 Invictus games
that's from new news collection if you
ask us Megan and Harry definitely owe
nunu their firstborn in return for
bringing them together despite recent
controversy Megan's bestie Jessica
Mulrooney also makes our list the
Canadian stylist three children were in
Meghan's bridal party Ivy was a
bridesmaid and her twin brothers Brian
and John stole the show beaming while
assisting mm with her long veil and
train on her walk down the aisle if
nothing else hopefully Jessica's kiddos
and Archie will be the best of friends
[Music]
Aires cousins are at indle is another
likely choice for godmother a world
equestrian and Olympian she certainly
got skills she can pass along to Archie
and in addition to having a close
relationship with Harry and Welles Harry
is already godfather to Zara's youngest
daughter with hubby Mike Tindall plus
Zara is godmother to Williams firstborn
Prince George there's nothing like
keeping it in the family I'm gonna make
it my office moving on to our list of
Godfather contenders Harry has a slew of
close mates who seem to fit the bill but
our top choice is Charlie ban straw
benzine they've been friends for more
than 25 years and have even been in each
other's weddings we will do everything
we can to make sure that she's never
forgotten and and carry on all of the
special gifts as such that she was Plus
Harry's late mom Princess Diana was a
close friend of the Vance Robbins II
family so in a way choosing Charlie
would pay her homage she had this
incredible ability which he's kind of
inherited and I told him that reason
thanks very much to make feed people
feel at ease and make them feel that
everything's gonna be alright making
Elton John Archie's Godfather would be
another awesome tribute to lady die the
Rocket Man and the late Princess were
close friends not to mention he's
mentored Harry throughout the years she
could walk into a room of people and
make them feel as if everything was
great so think of the stories and wisdom
Elton could share with baby Archie and
what better way to keep Diana's legacy
alive the van cuts and brothers are also
going on our list William and Harry grew
up with Nicholas and William and Harry
has actually gone father - Nicholas's
daughter foreign who was an adorable
bridesmaid in his wedding
making Nicholas Archie's Godfather would
be the perfect way for Harry to return
the favor
I'm just but our absolute favorite pics
for a little Archie's godparents are the
Clooney's and the Obamas careful what
you wish for
we might be wishing on stars but who's
to say it couldn't happen
[Music]